It's the moment I've been waiting for
Yes, I'm gonna do a VMA fashion review later this week
So don't worry that'll happen but I want to do this first because this is for meee, and I need it
Taylor Swift debuted her music video for "Look What You Made Me Do" at the VMA's yesterday
So I'm gonna watch it for the first time on camera with you guys right now. Let's. do. this.
I'm. so. excited. even. though. my. monotone. wouldn't necessarily give you that impression.. okay Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my God
I'm shaking. That's normal for an adult woman to feel about another adult woman's art right? Oh my God. Oh my God
Oh my God. Oh my God guys ready? Fuck. I mean yeah, let's do it
Is it space? No it's Earth. It's apocalypse Earth. Is it Harry Potter? Oh so many questions. Graveyard. Who's dead? Taylor Swift's reputation is dead
The symbolism and metaphors
What? Thriller. Someone's not hydrating enough. She's so strong. Whoa. If...
That's how I could bathe,  I'd probably be more hygienic.
That's not gonna get you clean! That seems like it's going to chafe. Snakes snakes snakes snakes snakes
But they're very accommodating. So hospitable. Ooh
Whoa! Oh my God is this
Nicki Minaj? Katy Perry?
Whoa. Whoa there's a cheetah!
Oh she's swinging. She's in a bird cage. She's in a cage. Metaphors. Now she's... Oh, that's not how you eat lobster. uh Oh
Cat Burglars. They're cat burglars. I want that sweatshirt so hard. Did that sweatshirt say blind follow? Give me that please
BDM Mmm Em. Oh now They're all tired. Ooh...
Business as usual. Wait, that's Todrick!
Oh my God, that's - Todrick's in this.
What you gotta be kidding me? Are you kidding?
Your hair looks wet. Whoa furries! Uh oh...
There's a bunch of you trying to get up to you. Oh to all the old versions of you! There's so much story!
There's so much symbolism. I think I'm getting hives. That's old Taylor. That's old Taylor, and they're all fighting. This is the new Taylor.
There they all go, I'm legit getting chills. They're all mission impossible
Why?
Cuz she's dead. Oh my God!
Todrick in these boots! What are you making ME do? What is she doing dancing? She could dance in heels
That's about as much as I can dance so...
She's so strong! Whoa. She's doing graffiti. She's doing illegal activity.
Why is she graffiting her plane?
Oh they all took their final bow.
They're fighting...
The narrative.
That was something (laughs).
I don't know how to think properly right now.
That was great, is my initial reaction. That was great. I saw headlines that people were like it's ripping off Lemonade
Me, I don't know. I just - both are really cool. This is gonna give me diarrhea.
That's how cool it is. My body is not functioning properly. I'm shaking. I'm sweating. Maybe this is just withdrawal? No.
It's just excitement about arts. It's a new
Taylor Swift era. Lucky us. I mean, it's no "Swish Swish"
Thank god.
Let me know what you guys think of the music video in the comments down below and don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel
Because I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes! Sometimes, I don't at all! Sometimes I put them up on other days.
So what what can you believe? Look what you made me do. I don't know.
-burp- Oh my God my body is malfunctioning.
What's fun?